welcome to this video playing the night
the Kenai something like that okie dokie
some whatever here english symmetrical
maybe add hedgehog doing that job okay
okay yeah there's a line that you have
some good experience with let's see I
think that 96 it's not so bad here
didn't do that okay now probably rook c8
as knight c6 looks a bit bit annoying
can I go G for radio and then let's just
do one more prep move here and now push
g4 yeah yes to go I know g 6 h-6 this
one ok well if I go g5 he can take and
go night if five I guess so aged 40 s
that is that you lose if maybe it is but
if six is something that is some you
know black has to be careful with such a
move ok batik now ok they'll go to six I
guess but it's not exactly exactly easy
to play now am I have some very simple
ideas just push step forward wow I
thought gee five at least ok I'm 95
stats already doing the trick or gauge
10 gauge one is good right that must be
good ok 95 that's at least he cannot
take it and that's probably bad news if
he cannot take it 95 he has to cook
Queen to d8
and a couple of things working now this
is also i think pretty strong let's do
that rook takes rook age seven King
takes Queen age three is that Yin I'm
threatening Bishop g7 i Luke Giselle I
thought that this is pretty convincing
by the way I didn't upload the game
before that which are lost because I
thought that was an engine abuser and to
be honest I was just cursing a little
bit too hard there I couldn't upload
that and so now i have just go back home
i just got back here I think setting up
for doubling on the H file okay I should
started with 95 actually would have been
would have been a little bit more
precise yeah allowing the commune trade
is not not exactly brilliant
oh that was bad shouldn't have allowed
the Queen trade so what to do now route
the three I guess covering III and c3 so
that'd be 50 d 5 is not hitting i also
have a great end game I don't I mean
that was it should have been ended by
cheque made this game but it's not a big
issue if it isn't it's still a pretty
good position so taking I'm a pawn up
and have a good good structure even
though it should have been ended by
cheque made definitely but bad that I
didn't mean someone didn't manage that
you
okay i can take before yeah I think I
will ok so and let's see five coming
here I think I can just try to get the
six as well
check
here and take these six next don't see a
problem there a 2 is also covered by the
night I mean my night not my opponent oh
I just blundered f1 that's a bad idea
stupid witch ok I could have taken d6 I
believe check just here and as disabled
is always hanging check
time warning 57 seconds check check 9500
didn't see that one coming check doesn't
matter though how to do it f5 is
probably the easiest for two passes
no learn more tech signs yeah I should
have really checkmated him there that's
a bit of a shame after this brilliant
position here yeah this is this is close
to lost right add the engine is on plus
3 or something age 5 and quite amazing
that i didn't manage a check made him so
night is six years the strongest but
that should also do the trick when i
played and here he i forgot i t5 of
course him just just do this and and we
wouldn't the Queen iya double attacking
everything him I was just thinking okay
let's go back Oh 95 next and
everything's good but he can do this and
get to queens off you know I didn't see
that that I get the Queen's traded ya
tienen I mean it is still like plus
three or something but it felt bad to
not have sent major turn I just hope
that I didn't screw anything up okay
this wasn't a back big problem as some
after this I'm still big material out
check check check don't think I gave him
any of anything here yeah i think the
the defeat here is coming down to that
age six move a little bit or at least
here he has to do something else here
even though it is definitely risky likes
play to allow this with h6 whenever I go
g5 you have to open some kind of file I
mean you can't give me the H file or let
me take their just accelerates why it's
a techie on the Kings side and difficult
the engine wants to play h5 and this is
already gone
we're thinking g5 is a little bit tough
love it but that's also I mean I'm
ticket it looks pretty awful I just have
a big attack and that's not even the
best continuation probably okay well
thanks for watching